you were talking earlier when you came
in so you you [ __ ] with psychedelics
pretty heavily uh you did Yes
Man all the way so you say you've done
DMT yeah whatever what was that like I
said man it was yo man
amazing words that's
it's like hard to explain Express right
like yeah you think I'm saying but it's
uh it's it's it's it's it's it's lovely
man it put you on so much of a higher
surface if I'm saying that when you can
see life front to back you know what I
mean and just like what they said last
15 minutes you know I mean and it felt
like you there for a lifetime you told
me you feel like you see life now after
the journey it's way more like
in a higher frequency you know what I'm
saying like thinking bigger if I'm
saying way larger like you know I mean
even the words you're using is careful
for me you're more careful with certain
things yeah where just understanding is
it's an ultra power install you know
what I mean Star Wars type how long ago
did you first try it uh so uh
suit like I tried my first one
if I had the pen the pen is not the same
right yeah I had the pen and then I had
wound up coming home because what
happened was I did it in Atlanta my boy
had wind up giving it to me before I'm
saying out there we was chilling out
there and um it was Bob see if I'm
saying it was Bob's and I was just like
kicking back I'm like when I get to La
I'm gonna do this the right way
yeah I'm ready
it's crazy crazy strong man and it it
took me out you know what I mean yeah
tell me how my body and then from there
I just was seeing the Galaxy being and
if I'm saying I'm in the Galaxy I seen
the land of fire I'm saying word like
you know I mean nothing but perception
no legs no nothing you for me but just
seeing the being and yeah it's just like
word is the soul presence I didn't seem
like
the the beans that was like
black Aura I mean black but we're right
over around them bro right before me it
was wavy bro like that before yeah yeah
you know what I'm talking about you but
I'm saying so it's like so I've never I
haven't done DMT I've done shrooms heavy
and I've had some pretty deep trips but
I heard DMT like you're not the same
like you see
you kind of like come out on the other
side of it I've had like people I know
say that they like were atheists prior
to that and then they do DMT and they're
like no there's a God it's like I saw
him or I felt that energy I felt that
presence of higher power what up that's
why I locked with your eyes man because
I feel like you know what I'm saying
words so how often are you shrooming you
micro dosing oh man definitely bro just
like yo anytime like anytime I really
like get my chance and I feel the vibe
too I'm really into but I'll be doing it
more than often like I I just gave it
like probably four days off just now
five days excuse me just micro doesn't
have a productive day right yeah what up
what up again that's when Johnny at the
time I'll be doing I'll be micro dosing
if I'm saying if I'm moving through the
day then when I get back to the crib you
know I'm into like five yeah man to take
it up and that's fire man yeah